science has been one of the most
influential forces in modern society but
it's a subject that is rarely the focus
of fictional film this video is
sponsored by audible you might think I'm
overlooking the science fiction genre
but the influence of science on the
genre is often contained to constructing
a setting for an otherwise traditional
story rarely our scientists and the
scientific process actually given the
spotlight often science fiction is
examining the outcome of a specific
technology science applied instead of
the scientific process involved with
discovering or producing that technology
to see an example of this you have to
look no further than modern science
fiction Twilight Zone Black Mirror which
is hardly concerned with the actual
science of what it presents merely the
social and individual ramifications of
those technologies sometimes to the
level of caricature in fact much of how
science and scientists are presented in
film involves some level of caricature
we often see scientist as crazed madman
or science as voluntarily or
involuntarily spawning some kind of
monster or hero consider the common
theme of super heroes or villains
created in a lab by accident science is
an out-of-control force directed by
irresponsible scientists and whether
what it produces is a force for good or
evil is a product of chance even when
the scientist creation of a hero is more
measured and intentional a scientist is
presented as a self-absorbed egomaniac
scientists often merely exist to spout
exposition when needed or as the pawns
of those who hold the real power even
films that seemed to give science a
closer examination paying a lot of lip
service to its name you want to talk
science hit record the facts analyze get
to the how and the why and present your
conclusions often end up casting it
aside in favor of other answers to the
stories central conflict love is the one
thing we're capable of perceiving that
transcends dimensions of time and space
maybe we should trust that even if we
can't understand it yet I'm not saying
that all these films are bad because
they portray science in this way but why
is this why is the scientific process so
often overlooked in film science fiction
author Aldous Huxley in his essay
literature and science examines the
divide between science and the literary
arts talking about authors he says they
have not been greatly interested in the
science as a set of logically coherent
hypotheses validated operationally by
experiment and dispassionate observation
and in the field of applied science
their concern has been mainly with the
social and psychological consequences of
advancing technology very little with
its working or it's underlying theories
Huxley's words could be describing the
tech film that is fascinated with the
interpersonal drama surrounding the
creation of a technology more than with
the creation of the tech itself but you
might say logically coherent hypotheses
and dispassionate observation are not
the grounds for great stories stories
are about passion feeling and emotion
and you might be right Huxley goes on to
describe how both science and literature
use language to describe things but it's
the nature of what each needs to
describe that's different the language
of science seeks for clarity and purity
in terms of specificity it seeks to
describe what Huxley calls public
experiences or those experiences that
are external and in that way shared by
individuals the literary artist takes a
different approach using language to
accurately portray private experiences
the world with which literature deals is
the world in which human beings are born
and live and finally die the world in
which they love and hate in which they
experience triumph and humiliation hope
and despair the differing goals create a
challenge when presenting science and
film reconciling the two is no easy task
but it's one that Huxley thought was
possible
one step something that Huxley suggests
to authors in his essay is to include
more relevant science within the work
itself and you can see this happening
more and more frequently multiverse
theory has been explicitly useful for
certain stories for interstellar
christopher nolan drew heavily on
cutting-edge science to produce accurate
visualizations of a black
whole but fear might creep into the
filmmaker that the science included in
the film will become outdated making the
films feel irrelevant in a way it might
not if the details were kept more vague
or a filmmaker might worry that those
details will be inaccurate making the
story feel immediately irrelevant to
those who are more scientifically
knowledgeable and so filmmakers focus on
portraying and discussing the emotional
philosophical and relational fallout
that the effects of science and
technology have had and really focus on
the science itself or they sidestep the
science in favor of a pseudo
metaphysical solution but this doesn't
account for the entire separation
Huxley's essay was partially written in
response to a lecture given by scientist
and novelist CP snow called the two
cultures and which he described a
cultural divide between scientists and
authors at that time there was little
crossover between the fields of
professional artist and scientist and it
makes sense the level of dedication
needed to be a good scientist and a good
artist are high enough that taking on
both is unrealistic for most but I think
the cultural separation that snow
observed is slowly closing as Huxley
hoped it would literature now has many
good examples of that gap being bridged
and recently film has given us some
stories where science itself has played
a larger role let's examine a few of
those by coming up from the back end see
rather than changing the surrounding
temperature we'll just change the level
that I'll conduct the transition
temperature primer imagines the creation
of a time machine as if it were invented
in a garage like the personal computer
much attention is paid to the
progression of decisions and ideas that
lead to the discovery of the actual
machine and the subsequent tests
spinning around beating some more takes
a lot of money it's a rare moment when
the process of discovery itself takes
center stage ahead of even character
development primers depiction of science
can also help us see that the issue is
not always that most movies don't
accurately depict science but that most
movies don't attempt to depict the
process at all regardless of how do be
us the science and primer might be the
attention it gives to the process of
invention is unique in fact that writer
and director Shane Karras is an engineer
turned filmmaker is no surprise in the
face of overwhelming odds I'm left with
only one option I'm gonna have to
science the out of this the Martian
might be the film that does the best job
of bridging the divide between science
and film the movie itself is interested
in the details now I have 100 litres of
unused hydrazine at the MDV if I run the
hydrazine over an Iridium catalyst it'll
separate into n2 and h2 and then if I
just direct the hydrogen into a small
area and burn it much of the science
shown in the film is accurate and
science becomes the hero of the story
luckily I'm a botanist the scientist the
person who is able to overcome adversity
a triumph Antonio sent me ahead with the
scan she's still busy still growing
aggressively the fountain doesn't depict
much science itself but it's a unique
film in that it's almost completely
about a scientist and the act of science
instead of turning the scientist into an
adventurer or presenting spirituality as
something that overcomes science it uses
those images to show science as a
spiritual endeavor and an adventure on
its own
instead of showing love as the thing
that works when science has failed love
is the very thing that motivates the
scientific act these films show us ways
that the divide can be bridged and I
think there's plenty of room for more of
this type of exploration one response
I've seen to this discussion is that the
reason for the lack of depicted science
may have to do
with the mundane nature of the majority
of scientific endeavors but I don't buy
the theory filmmakers are great at
making otherwise boring things appear
interesting and I'm not insinuating that
science is necessarily superior to
things like human endurance or love
these very things are often what fuels
the progression of science itself
I think the romanticism of art works as
a check and balance against the threat
of scientific hubris you can see the
less than positive images of the
scientists shifting as society's fears
about what it might produce change as
the ringing the bomb left in cultures
ears is fading our focus turns to new
more pressing concerns the dialogue
between film and science might be more
important than we think I've been
focusing on Sciences influence on film
but it goes both ways
science fiction films make it into
scientific papers from time to time and
those films play a role in shaping the
kind of scientific development and
technology that society comes to one and
expect research even suggests that
cinematic depictions of space travel
helped shape public opinion about his
viability helping make it possible to
fund those endeavors science isn't going
to become any less influential in the
future and so finding more accurate and
nuanced ways to tell stories about it
couldn't hurt even attempting to tell
those stories at all as has so rarely
been done is a noble endeavor this video
was largely inspired by Huxley's essay
and I've been a little obsessed with his
writing lately his book brave new world
is an essential read and I'm happy to
say that you can get it for free as an
audiobook when you use my link
audible.com slash Thomas flight or text
Thomas flight to five hundred five
hundred and sign up for a 30-day free
trial
I love audible and I'm happy to have
them sponsoring this video I always hear
people talking about how great audio
books are for commutes and workouts and
they are but they complement so many
activities make your summer better by
pairing some great audiobooks with a
hike some time on the beach or a road
trip when you sign up for audible you
get a book a month for your first month
I'm recommending brave new world Huxley
sets the story in a disco
be in future but instead of highlighting
the danger of a government impose
dystopia like Orwell shows us in 1984
Huxley shows us a dystopia created by
technology that the inhabitants
unwittingly welcomed upon themselves
it's a story that I think is absolutely
relevant to today whatever book you
choose is yours to keep and that's
something I love about audible the books
you get are yours forever
sometimes I've gone back and re-listen
two books that I enjoyed two or three
times and if you're ever unhappy with a
book you can swap it out for another one
you really have no excuse not to give
audible a try so use my link
WW audible.com/asap xed thomas flight to
five hundred five hundred to get a free
audiobook and 30-day trial and listening
to audiobooks all the time so if you
have any recommendations let me know in
the comments thank you everyone for
watching this video I really appreciate
your views and your support and as
always thank you so much to my patreon
supporters go to patreon.com/scishow